j'ai d'abord général en tant qu africain
on ne refuse pas de justification ont
bloqués à l'entrée de la frontière
polonaise mais nous avons un casino
autorités nous essayons de nous mettre à
l'abri les livrer dans la ville stable
des lives ne sont pas des toiles abri à
l'ugta à kiev à kharkiv à odessa est-ce
que vous manquiez d'eau et de nourriture
on ne n'arrive pas à ces substances est
en fait on n'arrive pas à
s'approvisionner d'eau de nourriture
nous sommes livrés à nous mêmes nous
sommes quelques-uns de nos compatriotes
de nos frais de toutes nationalités qui
ont pu traverser la frontière ont
témoigné comme quoi ils ont bel et bien
été reçue
il ya les polonais qui donnent à manger
qu'ils donnent à voir l'état de côte
d'ivoire a pris les mesures nous pensons
que j'aimais déjà
voilà notre problème sera résolu on sera
à l'abri et nous avait été demandé de
regroupe tous les ressortissants
ivoiriens
est ce à dire